Stephen here says is creating a company
and intimate family relationship wife
and intimate family relationship is a
significantly more impactful experience
than Simply Having a beautiful original
front LTR and local community
um
that depends
depends on your wife
it could be the most miserable choice in
your entire life bro it could be the
worst thing you ever do
uh quite literally so that's that's
entirely dependent on you know who you
decide to you know put a ring on her
finger and a baby in her belly so
careful oh hang on I think we got Steve
here in the background Steve Steve is
that you is that is that your question
yes yeah Rich
all right yeah thanks for having me
yeah that's me can you hear me all right
yeah yeah okay you got a little more
hair in this picture over here looks
like you shaved your head since
okay yeah so
yeah
literally
um I I uh I became red pill like many
folks after going through a divorce
so you know I'm in my early 40s at this
point but you know I got my money right
had a successful career in
um you know in the capital markets and
so you know I find a lot of inner peace
with the meditation and you know
everything that I've been talking to
myself but now I'm looking at you know
the remainder of my life it's like
what's the next mountain to climb and so
I'm wondering is it good to go out and
you know create a family do you have
kids right now
I don't have children
okay no so
so your first marriage netted no
children but you had the experience of
the marriage didn't work out
why didn't you have any kids with that
wife
well when it that's when the rubber came
to the road when it was time to you know
have kids afterwards for a few years and
it was okay
enough time to have children that's when
she decided she wanted to have a divorce
and you know try to
take my wealth from me so um it was a
bad choice in the beginning
but yeah well for me it's not something
that I really have a burning desire
but it just seems what else to do
because I'm not really motivated much by
my material things I have you know I
have a nice car I have nice
all the things that I would want you're
not really wanting for more but that's
why I wonder if focusing on
relationships is sort of the next the
next month let me get you just uh from
that wrist to roll the dice like you're
saying
Steve uh let me just stop you for a
second let me just get you to roll your
cursor down to the bottom and hit stop
cam just to kill your video feed
um because the audio keeps breaking up I
I need the audio more than I need the
video just so I can hear what you're
saying so just kill the video there you
go all right let's try that again so
um you're how old right now
a 41.
okay and is kids something that you want
or is it like I've made enough thinking
that's money in the capital markets
you're retired I'm effective
it's kind of that I'm bored you know I
am still active in the markets to do
with my time but none of these things
are like long-term projects if you know
what I mean where do you live looking
for something to you know spend 10 years
doing
okay where do you live man
I live in Tennessee
okay
um that's a father friendly state so
that's good
um I think shared custody is default
there so you probably wouldn't have to
fight over that
um you would you would want to spend a
couple years vetting the uh chick so
the standard protocol for your ask is
really spin some plates
uh let the cream rise to the top she's
gonna at some point say Steve I dig your
Vibe I want to claim you I don't want to
share you sort of thing I'm looking for
something serious when that gal shows up
then you take a look at her you take a
serious look at her you see if she's got
you know a bunch of red flags or not if
she doesn't then you can decide at the
time okay
I'm still kind of interested in kids
she's young enough to have kids she
doesn't have any red flags I like her we
get along and then you want to date her
for a couple years year and a half to
two years because women can act for I
think
um my psychiatrist friend Sean said that
they can act for about a year and a half
to two years so you want to date them
for about a year and a half two years
travel see how she handles stress
um you know difficult situations
see if she has the bright the bright
Triad traits rather than the dark Triad
traits and if it looks good then put
some babies in her you know if you want
to have some kids
um I'm not a big fan of marriage so I
wouldn't do it you know by inviting the
state in my house in the ceremony and
all that sort of stuff but you can have
children with the women you know if you
like her
you know she's good too she crosses off
you know she takes all the boxes she's
never red flags sure you know if that's
what you want then do it but
um I would structure your wealth in such
a way that there's some distance between
you and problems because you live in a
state where it's shared custody by
default
um what's that footballer's name Hakimi
you heard about this guy yeah
so he had nothing in his name
now
if you're with a a chick you're dating
her for two three years and then you
know she's pregnant all of a sudden uh
and halfway through the pregnancy you
move all of your assets out of your name
into your mom's name
and then the marriage doesn't work out
five six years later and you've got
three kids because you did that to
clearly and obviously protect your
assets before
um you know the first child was born
during her pregnancy the courts could
turn back the clock on that if she's got
a good lawyer depending on what the law
says where you live right so from from
day one before you get married you might
want to structure your wealth in such a
way that is protected and you can talk
to a family lawyer about how to do that
in your state but there's probably going
to be some options that will be
presented to you you see what I'm saying
like as far as the wealth part goes but
what you're really doing is you're
vetting her for mother's stock
yeah I appreciate the Practical tips on
the wealth and the vetting process and
I've heard you talk about this before I
guess my real question for you because
you've talked about how you you know you
have Offspring is is that Dynamic that
relationship you know having children is
that is that really significantly
different than just having meaningful
relationships with with other people in
your life whether that's your co-workers
or yeah it's totally different yeah it's
totally different I mean when you've got
a child
and you look at them
it's funny there was a stand-up comic
that made a joke about this you know
because I'm you know because I'm
divorced so I can kind of relate you
said something along the lines of you
know you look at your kid and your kid
half looks like you and half looks like
somebody that you kind of hate right now
um but look man it's you know you passed
on your name you pass on your legacy you
pass on your genetic code
um it is the reason why we are on the
earth to scatter seed and do this
um it's it's totally different from
friendships like you'll probably
find that friendships and network and
community and doing stuff that you're
like I love going on Supercar rallies
with my friends I just love it it's it's
it's one of my favorite things to do I
I wish I could do it every day
um but watching a bunch of you know
tween girls playing baseball
it's my duty as a father to participate
in that and to do the driving around and
haul the [__] and you know bring kids
around if I got it sort of thing but
it's not as fun as hanging out with my
friends driving you know Supercar
rallies
just isn't so uh it's just a different
kind of fulfillment you know what I mean
yeah I hear you I hear what you're
saying I don't unfortunately I don't
know what you right but yeah but it is a
different kind of fulfillment that you
can't experience having great
relationships and friendships with other
guys or other communities that you're
involved in that you like it doesn't
matter if it's like model building or
golfing or whatever that you know that
thing happens to be that you build it
around uh I think children are just
different in that sense and it's a
moving Target small children are
wonderful
um from the age of of birth to like two
or three sucks the first couple years
blow diapers screaming all night just
sucks okay and then they start to have a
little bit of a character and they're
fun and you take them to the park and
from that age up to about seven eight
nine ten cool and then they kind of like
move into that period where they're
turning into like more of an adult and
you don't matter so much anymore you're
now a taxi service you're an ATM you're
uh you know can I stay out over here and
do this with this person and they're
looking for permission if they don't
like it they get all hissy and [__] like
that and then your job is to parent you
know your job is to set boundaries and
guidelines around that child so they
have the potential to to do something
useful with their life to make you proud
you know what I mean
um so it's a lot of work and it's a lot
of fighting too
yeah okay well thanks for sharing your
experience and Rich thanks for
everything you do I really appreciate
you you're welcome Steve and I uh you
know hope you get and do whatever it is
that you want that uh you know fills
your cup my man all right the key thing
is though is is don't have kids just to
have kids I'm going to tell you this you
know before you go have kids with the
right woman make sure that you select
the mother's stock correctly because
that will make your experience that
could make your experience a [__]
living nightmare a complete hell to
Absolute Bliss I know I know guys that
are still married to their wives their
kids are all adults they've got great
family everybody's wonderful sort of
thing it's rare but it takes it takes
the right man in the right masculine
role to lead and the right woman to want
to follow that leader if you know what I
mean and to be a compliment to his life
and like there's a lot of things to
contemplate you know if you have small
kids and you've got the means I wouldn't
put them in the school system I would
homeschool them and I would have a
mother that was willing to homeschool
them so I mean if I could go back in a
time machine and do it over again I
would certainly set a certain list of
parameters and prerequisites that would
need to be met if I were to ever have
kids with a chick otherwise she would
just be for fun or she would just be for
entertainment or something casual and
I'd have other chicks on the go and I'd
wait for you know which one to like
stand out and be obvious to me that
would be good mother stock
the hard way you know with divorce but I
find it's it's easy to spin plates now
you know
um but it's when I think about it
realistically from a timeline
perspective you know I'm already in my
early 40s finding good mother stock you
know with the age Gap difference and
then taking the time to vet them and so
forth I mean this really kind of pushes
it out so I'm just wondering you know do
I put effort into something that may
that might might not have a high
probability of materializing or do I
just continue to chase Excellence you
know in business and
um you know internal experience I
wouldn't chase women I would Chase
excellence and if you're dating anyway
like is that what you're doing
well I mean I I travel around the world
so you know as I travel around I got you
know different women I talk to in
different places parts of the world but
I I literally live in an awesome when I
I'm in monk mode like for real like I I
spend hours a day meditating
um you know I live in a community and
it's really great and with the rest of
the time I spend you know pursuing
excellence in my business career it's a
unique situation I have here but you
it's not the best opportunity to like
meet women on a daily up here yeah you
would be a really good candidate for my
one percent Community I've got lots of
really good members in Tennessee dude
there's there's some very good friends
of mine that live in Tennessee that
would get along great with a guy like
you so
um I mean if you're looking for
Community if you're looking for a lot of
like-minded men that you can chop up
ideas like this and do more than just
what you're at right now then I would
definitely get into that that's that's
always pinned in the top comment of my
videos but um you sound like a solid
dude that's asking the right questions I
would I would keep chasing the
Excellence obviously you like women so
date women
um you're gonna have to make some
changes on how to do that a little bit
better
um and then if it's it's obvious and
clear that you've got a woman in your
life that's worthy of putting babies in
then contemplated them but only after
you test her for a few years to see how
she Stacks up because
women today are not like
we we have to work today as men probably
two three four five times as hard to get
a woman that's half as good as what my
granddad got honestly dude women today
aren't as good as what our grandfathers
you know could get and uh they're a
little messed up with the lifestyle
choices and everything that they've gone
through you know sort of their younger
more formative years if you know what I
mean
yeah I hear you rich you've been
gracious with your time thank you sir
you're welcome Steve take care I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out